Good morning, Hank. It's Tuesday.
It’s Thanksgiving week here in the United
States, so today I thought I would share with
you a story of gratitude.
So several months ago, Sarah got me tickets
to see the musical Hamilton in New York City,
and I should say that Sarah and I are both huge
fans of Hamilton.
Like, we’ve listened to the cast recording
hundreds of times, and now we were gonna have
this once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to see
the show with the original cast, and we were
gonna go to some art galleries and visit all
our favorite places from back when we were
first married and lived in New York.
So we got to the airport a little early, and
hurray our flight was on time, so we settled
in to an airport bar for some snacks, and
we were debating whether I should direct message
Lin Manuel Miranda, who, not to brag, follows
me on Twitter, and generally just feeling
sort of giddy, and then I took a bite of my
sandwich and more or less immediately knew
that we were not going to see Hamilton after
all.
A bit of relevant background: I have this
weird disease called eosinophilic esophagitis.
Basically, I have this mild-ish inflammation
of my esophagus, which usually is not a problem,
but then very occasionally, food will get
stuck part of the way down my esophagus, and
that’s a real bummer because when it happens,
I can’t even successfully swallow my own
spit, so I just sort of throw up every two
or three minutes for several hours until a
doctor sticks a tube down my throat and clears
the blockage.
So okay, I can’t even peel away all the
layers of luck and privilege that led to this
moment of misfortune in the Indianapolis airport:
the ability to afford a broadway show and
a trip to New York city, the joy of a spouse
who loves you enough to get you Hamilton tickets,
access to excellent medical care so your esophagial
blockage is an inconvenience rather than a
catastrophe. The list goes on and on.
But still, I was pretty bummed out when we
had to leave the airport and go to the hospital.
Now of course it wasn’t hard to find a happy
home for our Hamilton tickets, and the airline
(thank you, Delta) was amazingly cool about
refunding our tickets.
But yeah, I was still in a pretty foul mood,
partly because I was vomiting every two minutes,
and partly because I don’t love being reminded
that what I think of as myself is in fact
wholly dependent upon an unreliable and unpredictable
machine called my body.
Okay, so after several hours at the hospital,
a woman named Carmen came by to transport
my hospital bed and me to the endoscopy room.
Along the way, she asked if I had kids, and
I said “yeah,” she said, “It’s nice
that your wife can stay with you as you go
through this,” and I was like, “Well,
we’re supposed to be on vacation together!”
And then she said, “Maybe after you guys
get home tonight, you can watch a movie together.”
And I was like, “Maybe.”
And then she said, “So you’re married
and you have kids.
Do you like your job?”
And I said, “Yeah.”
And then she says, “Well, you’ve got the
basics covered.”
And then I was in the OR, and then I was unconscious,
and then I could swallow again, and I woke
up thinking, “Well, I’ve got the basics
covered.”
That night, Sarah and I went home and watched
a movie.
It was a pretty good movie, actually.
Since then, I’ve thought about that day
and Carmen many times.
I love my friends and family, and I am loved
by them.
I’ve got the basics covered.
Okay, so flash forward six months to last
week.
We’ve just started filming our new health
and fitness show 100 Days.
Starting January first, you can watch my best
friend Chris and I try to have a healthy midlife
crisis over at youtube.com/100days.
Anyway, as part of the show, we have to exercise
six days a week, often at very odd hours because
of our work schedules.
So last Wednesday, I had to wake up at 5:10
in the morning to go to a spin class, and
I was not psyched about it.
So I walk into this spin class, and there’s
Carmen.
And she says, “Hey, John, remember me?”
And I say, “Yeah.”
And she says, “I’m your spin instructor.
This is what I do before work.”
And of course, it turned out to be an excellent
spin class.
So, this Thanksgiving, I am grateful to Carmen.
When you are kind to strangers, you never
know what it’s gonna mean to them, but sometimes
it means a great deal.
So thank you, Carmen.
Happy Thanksgiving.
End screen!
Here you’ll find some old Thanksgivingsy
vlogbrothers videos, as well as a self-care
bunny from Rosianna who is here to remind
you that Carmen thinks you’re awesome, and
she knows from awesome.